communing the [ __ ] it's Wednesday you
know what that means
overdue Doctor Who review time and we
are now up to the episode of series
three known as gridlock and you know
this one's an odd one for me for a
number of reasons because I like it I
actually like it quite a bit but when I
actually try to analyze it there's a lot
that is wrong with it
like demonstrably wrong with it yet at
the same time I do enjoy it I think the
things that it does right just kind of
get me in the right way so this is the
episode where the doctor takes Martha to
new New York or new new new new new new
new however many it is New York which of
course he did with rose once before back
in new earth and he takes Martha there
and it's very clear to the audience and
then clear not that much further into
the episode - Martha that he's he's
trying he's doing kind of a combination
of things he's trying to recapture what
he had with rose yet at the same time
he's also he also seems to be afraid of
having unique experiences with Martha
because he'll get less attached that way
that one's not made as explicit but
that's partly my interpretation on that
as being a factor so last time we dealt
with sort of the upper echelon of new
New York and you know we met the Duke of
Manhattan and you know these highfalutin
figures this time we started out at the
Jay
way down at the bottom rung and
initially they land in pharmacy town so
originally named where all these vendors
these sort of street vendors are self
basically selling moves you sell a
little patch that you put it on and to
feel a certain way and there's a certain
amount of manipulation obviously the
popular one that they're pushing is
happy but we also see a woman by forget
so that she will forget her parents
because her parents went to the motorway
and everybody goes to the motorway
eventually and when they do you don't
see them anymore
now this whole segment with the mood
drugs is kind of the first problem with
the episode there's nothing wrong with
the idea in fact it's a pretty good idea
that is kind of the problem
it feels wasted here because it exists
really only to ultimately pay off at the
end of the episode when we find out why
the situation is what it is
how we got here and what happened and it
serves that function it's not like it
doesn't work as an explanation for how
we got here but I feel like this whole
idea of people buying selling trading
moods states of you know actual very
direct and specifically altered states
of mind I think that had a potential to
be something more than this and the
other thing is that it doesn't fit the
matically with the rest of what's going
on and what the rest of the episode is
doing so it's not like a natural
marriage to what makes up the bulk of
the episode which is the gridlock the
traffic jam so Martha gets kidnapped by
the by the card by the carjacker so that
they can have three people in their car
which gives them access to the fast lane
which sounds good but really isn't I'll
get back to that so I really do love the
main core premise of this thing which is
literally the traffic jam
hell where people are waiting years to
go just a few miles you get on the
motorway
your destination is say five miles away
if you get access to the fast lane
you'll be there in six years we meet
people have been on the motorway for
over 20 years and it's it's a really
good simple sci-fi premise what's
something that everybody can relate to
what's something everybody gets traffic
oh god right well let's go big with it
let's go big and insane and I like that
I like things that can start from that
premise I think a lot of great genre
stuff be it fantasy be it sci fi be it
horror starts with what's this thing
that people understand okay how do we
exaggerate it for the genre we're in and
I enjoy that quite a bit when it's done
well and I do feel for the most part it
is done well here it helps that a lot of
the other motorists that the doctor
encounters when while he's trying to get
to Martha are pretty pretty likable
folks well mainly we have Brannigan
who's one of the cat people and no I'm
not actually gonna complain about the
cat people all that much this time
because unlike the nuns the cat nun
nurses Brannigan is really enjoyable and
so the fact that the design of them as a
creature you know for lack of a better
term I still find to be a lazy choice i
I like him I like his energy I like his
rapport with his wife and and I just
enjoy him as a present so I don't mind
the cat makeup so much so I think that
sort of shows that the as much as I
complained about the cat nuns back in
new earth that the fact that they were
cats wasn't the core of my problem but
it became a bigger issue for me when
there wasn't other things about them
that
working so I was just seeing that as
more of a flaw whereas here it's not
something that I love but it's not
distracting from what I like about this
guy so that's a really fun performance
and and really they're all good the
carjackers are quite good and those two
are actors who went on to do other stuff
since and I've seen other stuff so
that's kind of cool to go back and see
them but they're they're very likeable
again they have a great rapport the the
monsters the Macra being down at the
bottom of the motorway in the smog are
not needed the the officer just didn't
need a monster and they don't add
anything I think that if they wanted to
put Martha in a more immediate sense of
danger there were a lot of other ways to
do it you there could have there there
is mentioned several time of pirates you
know being a thing that are on the
motorway you could have had pirates have
been the problem as opposed to these
monsters that seemed very detached from
the proceedings and aren't a natural fit
for what Scott I mean it's kind of a
cool nod because the Macra actually the
macro terror animated recreation is I
think well it'll be out by the time this
comes out I think it just got released
at the time of recording so but you know
the macro was a largely forgotten
classic doctor monster and I mean this
is this a fun enough way to get them in
there but again they don't serve a
purpose and the monsters don't help it
reminds me of the problem that I had
with Father's Day and the Reapers which
is that this story is not aided by a
monster of the week in fact the monster
feels shoehorned in and is kind of
actively hurting the narrative and
thankfully it's not as egregious as the
Reapers were I think they were really
detrimental to
Thursday the Macra art to that degree
but is cut from the same cloth
so they do still kind of irritate me
because they don't help
they don't assist the story in any way
the stuff at the end with the face of
BOE is one of those things that works
better on a rewatch than it does on
initial viewing because the rapport
between the two of them which is very
old friend but in the context of the
show up to this point they've met twice
that we know of and so like this feels
weird and unearned of course though he
drops the bomb the you are not alone
bomb and that'll pay off quite nicely
down the road but you know we'll get
there so I think aside from just the
fact that I enjoy the core premise of
this whole episode I think the the
strongest materials actually probably at
the end where Martha basically confronts
the doctor with the fact that he's not
being open with her about who he is
about why he's travelling with her about
a what why he misses Rose he's not being
honest with her he's probably not being
honest with himself which he admits to
and I like the way she does she
basically just sits down I'm not going
anywhere until you talk to me and it's a
nice moment of strength from her and it
actually gets him to open up I would
actually say to a degree that we never
saw him do with Rose I'm not gonna say
go so far as to say he never did it with
Rose I think you know they traveled
together enough that one could presume
he told Rose about Gallifrey with some
of the details and to the extent that he
that he tells Martha but we never saw
him do that so it it feels like a nice
sort of bomb on their pretty rocky
relationship up to this point that he's
opening up to her with a greater amount
of detail and certainly far earlier than
it probably would have
with rose if it even did happen because
as I said we didn't see it so that's a
good moment which again helps I think I
complained in the Shakespeare Code that
that they I mean I don't like it as a
thing in the first place but the whole
the Martha pining for the doctor got
kicked into high gear way too dang soon
and there's a little bit of that here
but I feel like this episode still comes
in in a good place as far as that
relationship goes because Martha being
in such immediate danger and it being so
hard for the doctor to get to her again
gives her it gives him a better
appreciation of the fact that he has not
bothered to get to know her yet and it
gives her a better appreciation of the
fact that she doesn't have any a clue
who this guy is and it kind of forces
them to try and start to deal with that
which is good for their relationship I
can't remember if it that just ends up
kind of getting rolled back or just
back-burnered in the in the episodes to
come but unfortunately because the
episodes to come is uh is a two-parter
that I'm not looking forward to but
that's next week for right now that's
gridlock an episode with a number of
really unnecessary and easily fixed
problems and yet I still I still enjoy
it I mean the the faults are irritating
in in how simple they are to fix but I
do still enjoy this thing as cheesy as
it is it may be that's part of you why I
like this one and also the music's
really good in this and I'm pretty sure
it's the first use of all the strange
strange creatures so whatever your
thoughts may be drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about a
whole bunch of stuff down there to do
cuz there's buttons links the patreon
it's my birthday this month so I got my
Amazon wish list down there as well if
you're feeling generous plus there's the
PIO box if you want to send me something
not from the the wish list I swear I'll
stop all this
was shameless self Schilling once the
month of March is over but for now why
not check it out or don't that's okay
too because at the end of the day you're
the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]